i'm so excited and i'm salivating i'm i
love food i love eating i skipped lunch
so that i could tear through all of this
stuff and not because i'm on a diet
because i needed room i get it i was
like i have to just make space um what
are we making we're making a cubano
which is a very traditional yeah it's a
very traditional recipe we're gonna do
it in a tortilla is that okay yes okay
so we we have let's i'm gonna show you a
little fold hack that's fun so we're
just gonna take this tortilla now you
can go like that if you want just to to
warm it up that's how you do it you just
go like this in here there's what that
does is there's moisture in here it just
wakes it up yeah you know i see nice
warm it's a little more it's a more it's
like it's loose right so you're just
gonna cut down here
like a little
that okay let me show everybody
that's it and then we have four quad
quadrants
one
one two three four
one two three four take your pick go
okay there's no race i'm sorry
everything is a race on the food network
good amount of mustard you really need
mustard okay i love mustard okay i'm
gonna take the cheese with my hands okay
cause i'm eating this
and you need cheese i mean cheese
is everything on this sandwich
then
the ham what i like to do
is i like to just sort of
fold a couple pieces like this one two
okay
just a lot of ham you want to put all
that ham that's just for display but
we're staying within the restricted
boundaries of the quadrants
okay boundaries understood
and then press a bit
just a little bit just a little smoosh
and then don't fold this one this way
fold it that way so the weight
magnifies the pickleness of everything
so we'll just pull a touch of this not
too much
and there we go
now we did one which is sad
so if you put this in you leave it a
little too long it's okay the cheese has
to be like a cheese pull it has to be
like that so should we have a bite yes
please
oh look at that crisp leave it cook and
it's it'll tell you when it's done it
has a little signal i don't know why i'm
making such a big deal about picking the
piece if you don't like one of those you
just pick another one
okay
oh it's good cheers cheers i'm nice
four ingredients
[Music]
what's so perfect about this sandwich
is the balance
you've got
the yummy pickle the protein the cheese
it's so simple that mustard is such a
perfect cake you sound like a chopped
judge did you notice she gave all those
little taste points and that was very
good i want to have you on the show you
have no idea
what do you think about her as a chopped
judge right
it's hard to chop a kid though
if they chop a 12 year old stuff my kids
and i have seen almost every episode
made of chopped junior i've seen every
episode of chopped
i've been your biggest fan for so many
years and i've loved watching you
we know you're like one of the world's
greatest chefs but the way that you come
across as we watch you you're it's
really
i i just love you as a human being so
much wow oh my gosh thank you
how's the sandwich
it's so good
i was going for the third bite i'm done
already chefs eat fast speaking of you
on television big restaurant bet um big
restaurant bet
it is
10 o'clock in food network on tuesday
um
it's great it's just everything
oh my god look what i did i know i
probably did the same thing
does that happen to people oh yours is
good she you win i lose and i'm like and
yet i would totally eat this i'm gonna
make another one
big restaurant bet
it's um we've found eight of the best
chefs in the country they're thousands
we found eight
and they all want to have a restaurant
their dream
is
to have a restaurant which is so hard to
do
especially now
and we put to my wife and i my wife runs
our company so my wife and i are the
judges such a family yeah and it's funny
because it was like roll the camera and
we they put the food in front of us and
we just like started talking like we do
and it was like that's the show
so but we threw in all these terrible
terrible things that are going to happen
to you because they happen to us
someone walks out
someone burns something someone gets
nasty in the dining room uh the the gas
go you know all this stuff you got to
manage because now you're a chef you're
a great chef now you're an owner guess
what that means you get we shovel you
all the problems of the restaurant that
you never knew existed and the audience
is going to find out how really awfully
hard
it is to actually open the restaurant
the greatest chef in the world doesn't
mean is going to be successful i have to
say nobody has ever shown what that
journey is we've only heard
how it's difficult but nobody knows how
it functions and nobody knows what it
really looks like and you're showing the
seams and taking people behind an
industry that we are all dying to know
how it functions bravo to you for this
fresh concept thank you very much
seriously no thank you because i think
it's important like
it's it's a competition show
but but the prize is not glory the prize
is the the ascent of the glory maybe
uh if you do it right and so that the
winner gets my wife and i to consult
with them and we give them all our
resources our time our energy and we
help them
like watch out for the the the barbed
wire and watch out for the problems that
are going to happen well who better to
yeah it's good i don't give away we've
seen it all edge we have seen it all
[Music]
you